ah tennis the game were to this day you
have no idea how the scoring system
works my name is Emma laser let's get to
it the white tennis comes from Old
French 10 e or 10 a meaning to receive
which was most likely called by the
server to an opponent before he served
these French words were brought into the
English language by the Normans and
there were modified into 10s and later
on tennis tennis referred to Canada the
proto tennis called real tennis royal
tennis or in French you should a pawn
real tennis started in Europe around the
16th century Howard there was an even
older game dating back to the 12th
century friends where people used to hit
balls with their hands and it was only
when real tennis came along that a
tennis racquet was added to the game and
the court moved into an enclosed space
real tennis was a huge success within
the European nobility especially in
France where the game was encouraged to
play by France is the first of France
not only between Nobles but also between
commoners the tradition of French kings
playing and encouraging real tennis
continued by a list of French kings for
example Charles de 9 who granted a
constitution to the corporation of real
tennis players and created a first
tennis tour in 1571 it crossed the
Strait in England the game of real
tennis card on 2 with Henry the fifth
but also Henry d8 who was set to play
the game with gusto and determination
there were lots of nobles and even some
common areas not just Kings who played
real tennis during this time and there
wasn't really a unifying set of rules
for real tennis just as you played the
same version of a card game with
different rules than your friend does so
did the nobles in Europe play real
tennis by house rules and this can be
seen in a book I can't pronounce which
was written by Antonia purely because of
the fact that he got fed up by all the
different rules and wanted to
standardize real tennis by writing a
book about it sadly this didn't happen
and slightly different versions of real
tennis were played all around Europe it
was also during this time that the
scoring of tennis may have evolved
although still very debatable by
scholars the 15 30 and 45 scoring of the
game may come from the fact that the
score was kept on a clock face where the
minute hand symbolized the score you had
and because to win a game the hand had
to finish a full circle 60 minutes it
had to move by 50 minutes every time to
finish that circle the 45 was later on
changed to 40 as The Deuce was invented
however in the 17th century under the
English Puritans Milton
lost popularity in England and in the
18th to 19th century even though the
Tennis Court Oath was very important
event in a French Revolution it still
doesn't help real tennis during the
Revolutionary period as it was seen as a
noble's game but with real tennis
falling out of favour in Europe new
racquet games emerged like rackets
squash and lawn tennis from which
today's tennis during the 19th century
there were several similar games of Lawn
Tennis designed the important ones being
designed by English Harry gem and his
friend algorri or Pereira and the other
by Walter Clopton Wingfield Harry's an
agarose game wasn't that much similar to
the modern tennis Howard they did start
the Tennis Club in lamington making it
the first Tennis Club in the world on
the other hand Walters Lawn Tennis was
most likely the true predecessor of
tennis even though his tennis was played
on an hourglass shaped court with the
net being even higher than hundred forty
centimeters and the Serb had to be
served past a service line rather than
in front of it
despite this his version of Lawn Tennis
was the most played game of Lawn Tennis
and spread around England Europe and
America again with everyone playing a
slight different variation of the game
but with so many variations of the game
being played around the world how did
they standardize it well that brings us
to the grand slam where the winner is
the person that can slam the ball the
hardest wait what it's not true tennis
always disappointing me anyway that
brings us to the granddaddy of all
tennis tournaments Wimbledon the first
and the oldest of the Grand Slams the
first Wimbledon was held in 1877 to
raise money for the All England Club the
winner of the tournament was called and
I quote the Old England Lawn Tennis Club
single-handed champion of the world
compensating for anything the first
tournament culminated in a significant
debate on how to standardize the rules
in the following year the tournament was
recognized as the official British
championship and the rules for British
Lawn Tennis became more standardised
across the ocean in the USA the rules of
Lawn Tennis vary from city to city from
Club to club and therefore in the 1881
United States national Lawn Tennis
Association was founded and later on
renamed to the USTA
it was this new Association that held
the first u.s. national men's singles
which later on became the US Open in New
Port Rhode Island apparently moved to
NYC later the first Australian Open was
held in 1905 but didn't really received
much attention all the way to the 1970s
to it seclusion for much of the tennis
playing world even though Lawn Tennis
was predominantly played in English
Arius it started to rise in popularity
in other countries too for example
friends we're the first French Open was
held in 1891 and was recognized as the
Grand Slam in 1925 in 1998 Dwight F
Davis of Harvard University wanted to
create a tennis tournament where US
would compete against Britain and so
created the International Lawn Tennis
Challenge this caught on with other
tennis playing countries and tournament
quickly became the largest between
nations tennis competition and the world
however following the death of Dwight
Davis in 1945 the tournament was renamed
in his honor to Davis Cup in which at
the turn of the millennia hundred and
thirty countries participated in the Fed
Cup on the other hand had a brush start
being rejected in multiple occasions
until 1963 when the Federation Cup was
played officially for the first time
1913 saw the creation of the
International Lawn Tennis Federation or
as it is known today the ITF also very
20th century Lawn Tennis evolved into
the tennis we know and love today in
1972 day TV was established to protect
the professional men's tennis players
from the business practices of the
professional tennis ters at the time and
a year later the WTA was created for
women professional tennis players in the
end the game of tennis went through a
lock kings nobles commoners deaths
revolutions complications
discriminations innovations so this
weekend when you turn on the TV and see
two people dressed in all white hitting
a weirdly colored ball with pans that
have holes in them think of the history
that led to death one
hello if you like the video I would
greatly appreciate it if you would
please share it I know it may sound like
a cliche but I'm a new channel and would
greatly appreciate the exposure thank
you